Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Allora, io vorrei raccontarvi una storia.
Siamo in estate,
in una località, in un villaggio,
in una regione della Cina.
In questa regione della Cina,
un uomo e un bambino,
con in mano delle gabbie di legno,
si muovono cauti nella campagna.
Noi vediamo che loro salgono
e scendono dagli alberi
con delle cassette,
e che afferrano qualcosa
dei rami degli alberi,
le inseriscono nelle cassette
e le chiudono.
Risalgono su un altro albero
e rifanno la stessa procedura.
Un gruppo di turisti italiani,
non per caso un gruppo
di turisti italiani, sono incuriositi.
La guida turistica dice
che si tratta di un insegnante
e di un suo allievo
che stanno portando delle cicale a scuola
per far conoscere ai bambini le cicale.
Tra i turisti c'è un insegnante
e naturalmente l'insegnante sapeva già,
quando ha sentito
il discorso della scuola,
che cosa avrebbero fatto.
Cosa poteva fare un insegnante,
portandosi dietro una cicala a scuola?
Può al massimo studiarla
dal punto di vista della scienza,
può anche dissezionarla,
può anche lavorare spiegando -
e direi non solo spiegando,
ma comprendendo insomma
la forma della cicala.
"No," dice la guida turistica cinese,
"La portano a scuola
per far sentire ai bambini
il canto delle cicale".
Come vedete è un altro punto di vista.
Gli insegnanti di solito
portano a scuola degli oggetti,
li sezionano a livello astratto
e a livello pratico.
Ma difficilmente, nell'Occidente,
portano un elemento
e fanno sentire il canto delle cicale.
Questa è una differenza.
Ma cosa vuol dire che è una differenza?
È una differenza perché noi
siamo storie di differenza.
Però attenzione, perché non solo noi,
io o tu siamo differenza.
La differenza sta
nella relazione che io stabilisco.
Non sta nella cicala,
ma sta nella relazione
che io stabilisco con la cicala.
Questa è la differenza.
E quindi proviamo a capire
cosa significa nella nostra vita
essere differenza,
non in quanto "sé".
ma in quanto "relazione con".
In quanto "relazione con",
quello che è importante viene detto
da un grandissimo antropologo,
psicanalista e psichiatra,
è che se noi, nella nostra esistenza,
rompiamo questa struttura
che connette la relazione,
rompiamo la struttura
delle nostre relazioni
che abbiamo con le cose e con gli altri,
noi corriamo il rischio di perderne
il valore e la qualità della alterità,
che siano cose o che siano relazioni.
Se perdiamo valore, perdiamo il senso,
non perdiamo la cosa.
L'altro può essere un nemico,
e quindi significa che io
ho una relazione con un nemico.
Ma l'altro non è un nemico,
quindi è nella relazione
che io sento che è un nemico.
Questa è la differenza.
Ed è importante intuirla,
allora siamo differenza.
Attraverso che cosa io riesco
a cogliere questo?
Siamo differenza piuttosto nel sentire,
più che nel comprendere.
"Nel sentire più che
nel comprendere" cosa significa?
Significa che il comprendere l'altro
assume quasi una posizione di funzione:
lo spiego, lo analizzo,
lo valuto, lo disseziono.
Questo è il comprendere.
Anche se c'è questo cum-prendere,
in realtà se io lo comprendo,
lo categorizzo.
Il sentire invece è diverso, ma
finisco col comprendere.
Attenzione perché il comprendere
è la ragione, la razionalità, quello
che volete voi,
non fa altro che strutturare.
E questa struttura diventa
a sua volta strutturante
e quindi è un continuo corrersi dietro
a strutturare le cose,
fino a renderle minimaliste,
fino a renderle quasi necessarie,
funzionali a un disegno minimo
della nostra intelligenza,
della nostra conoscenza.
Il sentire invece è qualcosa d'altro.
Perché nasce dentro,
nasce nelle intersezioni
che noi abbiamo dentro di noi
e in queste intersezioni
noi funzioniamo per relazione,
cioè la relazione che ci riguarda
è quella che ci permette di stare al mondo
perché noi siamo in relazione,
siamo differenza, siamo relazione.
E stiamo al mondo solo per la relazione.
Adesso vorrei fare con voi,
se siete d'accordo, un piccolo esercizio.
Ci state?
E allora provate
a sentire il vostro respiro.
Ascoltate il vostro respiro.
Fate rientrare lo sguardo,
guardatevi dentro.
Sentitelo.
Sentite il flusso del respiro
dentro di voi.
Sentitelo lungo il corpo,
le mani e i piedi.
Sentite che va oltre.
Sentitelo bene dentro.
Sentite l'onda, la forma,
il rumore, il suono,
i chiari e scuri, le forme.
Cercate di andare al di là,
oltre, oltre, oltre il respiro.
Quello che sentiamo
sono forme, flussi, circolarità.
Non sentiamo finito, determinato, lineare.
Il respiro interno
non ci porta alla struttura,
ma ci porta alla circolarità di senso.
La circolarità di senso
non è ancora comprensibile,
è ancora un sentire.
Però ci porta e ci fa emergere altro,
ci fa emergere altre alterità.
Questa circolarità ci porta, anche,
a qualcosa che è
ancora più profondo dentro di noi,
che non trattiamo quasi mai,
che è la risonanza.
La risonanza è quello che ci suona dentro
quando noi facciamo qualcosa,
o quando noi pensiamo,
quando noi sogniamo,
quando noi immaginiamo.
È quel qualcosa dentro
che non è espresso
in qualcosa di particolare.
Ricordatevi che la prima
risonanza nostra è il suono,
perché nel ventre della madre
la prima cosa che noi cogliamo è il suono.
Il suono dei passi della madre
e del ritmo della madre,
il suono dell'acqua dentro,
del liquido amniotico,
questo sentiamo e questo risuona.
E questa risonanza,
quando il bambino nasce,
rimane dentro, non resta fuori,
perché fuori usa altri canali.
Allora noi,
quando siamo in relazione
nei confronti di una cosa,
nei confronti dell'altro,
noi dobbiamo sentire la risonanza,
perché nella risonanza noi capiamo
perché abbiamo quella relazione.
Che tipo di relazione abbiamo
con l'alterità?
Qualsiasi alterità.
Quella relazione ci porta a capire
se siamo in grado di fare intersezioni,
se siamo in grado di fare contaminazioni,
se siamo in grado di costruire
qualcosa con l'alterità,
o se invece siamo fermi
nella nostra percezione razionale,
nella nostra struttura,
nella nostra linearità di Io, di identità.
Io sono io: no, io sono relazione.
E per fare questa operazione
bisogna fare tutto un lavoro
che è di capire il senso di questi flussi,
di queste forme che poi riconosco
negli atti concreti reali.
Quando incontro un uomo,
io sono una donna e sento una differenza,
quando incontro un migrante,
io sono un nativo.
Quando incontro un giovane,
perché io non sono un giovane,
sono un anziano.
Quando incontro l'Io e il Tu.
Ecco: io sento,
in questa relazione, un senso,
che mi dice che comportamento posso avere,
che comportamento ho avuto,
e che comportamento
potrò avere nel futuro.
Io devo spartire questo senso di me
con la differenza,
perché Benson diceva
che per entrare in relazione
noi dobbiamo perdere un po' di sé.
Non entri in relazione con niente,
neanche con il camminare,
neanche con il video, con internet,
se tu non perdi un po' di te.
E detto questo è chiaro
che noi possiamo capire questo
soltanto se apriamo
le menti alla complessità.
La complessità non è complicata,
non è infinita,
non è nemmeno il plurale,
non è nemmeno il multilaterale.
La complessità è un movimento continuo,
quelle forme che avevamo dentro di noi,
che ci dice effettivamente
come ci possiamo muovere
e che tipo di possibilità abbiamo.
Poi vedrete che tipo
di possibilità abbiamo.
Tenete presente che l'accesso
alla complessità non ci è stato dato.
Eppure la complessità è sempre esistita,
ma non ci è stato dato l'accesso.
Non ci è stato dato
da una forma di cultura
che ci ha impedito
questa libertà di relazione.
Perché quelle forme di culture
ci hanno portato ad accettare
il dominio di qualcuno sui molti.
Ci hanno detto che la mente
è diversa dal corpo
e che è gerarchicamente
superiore al corpo,
e ci hanno detto
che possiamo avere dei nemici.
Oggi ci dicono che i migranti
sono i nostri nemici,
che le donne sono le nemiche degli uomini
e gli uomini sono i nemici delle donne.
Ci dicono tutte queste cose,
che i vecchi sfruttano i giovani.
Ci dicono questo oggi:
è sempre quella cultura deterministica,
quella che ci struttura nel pensiero,
non quella che apre a tutti
e ci permette anche una scelta
e ci permette anche
di costruire le scelte.
Perché io non faccio scelta
se non la costruisco,
perché la scelta la faccio
nella relazione,
non faccio una scelta così,
"Io sono qui e scelgo lui
o scelgo lei": no.
Devo stabilire la relazione,
per fare la scelta.
Anche questo questo linguaggio,
"Decidete, scegliete, organizzate, fate",
si, va bene ma nella relazione.
Cioè quando conosco, quando sto,
quando mi situo, quando mi apro.
Come quel turista,
quell'insegnante che ha capito
che a scuola non si può fare
soltanto la dissezione della cicala.
Poi se analizziamo questa cosa
dal punto di vista
anche della sostenibilità insomma,
portare una cicala
a scuola nella gabbietta,
che poi grida disperata
perché è nella gabbietta,
non è questione di bontà,
è questione semplicemente
di punti di vista.
A me piacerebbe quell'insegnante lì
e io vorrei essere
come quell'insegnante lì,
e spero di diventarlo.
Forse alla mia età è un po' difficile,
ma io credo di esserlo.
Io credo di esserlo e penso che anche voi,
qualcuno di voi riesca, secondo me,
o sappia di esserlo
oppure si possa situare
su questa relazione.
Questo essenza di relazione,
fino a diventare che cosa?
Questa cultura ci ha usato,
ci ha abituato a strutturarci,
a categorizzarci in altro modo,
fino ad arrivare all'odio, al conflitto.
L'odio è peggio del conflitto.
Io ti odio.
Non so niente di te, ma ti odio.
Ho solo sentito parlare di te che ci sei.
Sei arrivato via mare.
Sei una donna e ti odio.
I figli, gli anziani,
tutti i professionisti.
Questa è la cultura dell'odio,
è la cultura della strutturazione,
del limite, della limitatezza
e del radicalismo.
Però tenete presente che allora
dobbiamo fare una cosa,
dobbiamo rieducarci
attraverso la relazione.
Dobbiamo rieducaci alla relazione,
alle differenze e dobbiamo trovare
un'altra grammatica di vita,
un'altra grammatica esperienziale,
un'altra grammatica di conoscenza,
una grammatica concettuale.
Perché è importante questo?
Ve lo spiego perché è importante.
Gli insegnanti sanno,
ma anche i genitori sanno questo,
tutte le persone secondo me sanno questo,
non occorre neanche che lo dica:
rieducare significa aprire le menti.
Ma non aprire elementi
nel senso dell'800, attraverso il sogno,
l'immaginazione ristretta
a quei campi limitati,
a quella zona local
dove noi siamo cresciuti.
No.
Che sia stata l'agricoltura,
che sia stata l'industria,
sono sempre zone "local".
Nella complessità la rieducazione
e l'immaginario che ci sta dietro
che è sempre esistito, sempre.
Anche qui ci è stato impedito,
o ci è stato limitato,
e ci è stato costretto
o ci è stato direzionato.
Questo immaginario oggi
ha più possibilità,
perché nella complessità
ci sono più possibilità,
più incertezze, più confusione.
Ma se io sto nella relazione,
la capisco e conosco,
vedo le resilienze e le opportunità
che ci sono dentro e fuori,
e dentro di me e fuori di me,
nell'altro, nelle cose,
nelle organizzazioni e nelle istituzioni.
Io allora devo pensare
che questa immaginazione
non dev'essere un sogno, un'aspettativa,
una probabilità che oggi hanno pochi,
ma una possibilità di vite diverse.
Una possibilità di vite diverse.
I giovani lo sanno
che se non trovano qualcosa qui
vanno da un'altra parte,
se non ce la fanno con quel lavoro
possono reinventarsi in un altro lavoro.
Noi dobbiamo puntare
alla possibilità di vite diverse
e questa possibilità ci viene data
dall'immaginazione,
perché oggi l'immaginazione è concreta,
è una pratica sociale.
E' una pratica che ci coinvolge in gruppo.
Attraverso una differenza,
io posso pensare altro.
Non posso pensare
a un'immaginazione aperta
dentro di me, dentro al mio
unico luogo ristretto;
la posso pensare solo se esco,
se incontro, se stabilisco relazioni.
E se queste relazioni
stabiliscono la differenza,
e non l'identificazione con l'altro.
Usciamo dalle identificazioni.
Lo dobbiamo.
A chi lo dobbiamo?
Lo dobbiamo alla nostra natura di umani.
Natura-cultura.
Non è natura e nemmeno cultura
ma è natura-cultura di umani
e anche di non umani.
Attenzione, perché dobbiamo pensare
anche ai non umani, comprese le cose.
Lo dobbiamo ai nostri figli, ai giovani
e lo dobbiamo a noi.
Lo dobbiamo alla nostra
e altrui diversità,
e a tutte le diversità
perché i giovani, noi, le diversità,
costruiranno il futuro.
Grazie.
(Applausi)